It is time for Drew's News.
When I say good, you say news.
Good!
News!
Yeah!
(audience cheering)
That was fun.
That's new.
I know!
I love it.
We've never done that before.
Thank you for trying it with us
and I gotta say it does feel really good.
And I'm also here with the best news man in the biz,
Rossy Ross Mathews.
Hi, everybody!
When you say good, they say news.
Yes, all right, well,
speaking of news, Rossy!
Well, first things first,
we gotta go over to Britney Spear's Instagram for a second,
like I do every single morning.
I don't know if you saw this, Drew, but did you see?
Britney posted that out of the thousands of celebrities
she's met in her life,
there are only two that have left her completely speechless,
Kate Hudson and Drew Barrymore.
(audience cheering)
How about that?
I love this, she said that instead of talking to you,
she was so flustered she just ran away from you.
And she also wrote that sisterhood is profound
and that she admires you so much, Drew.
Did you read this like when it just popped up
on Britney's Insta?
Everyone at the show, 'cause I was down here filming,
came running up to me and was like,
"Did you see, did you see?"
And then I just said, "I'll see it when I get upstairs.
I wanna be like thoughtful.
I wanna read every word that she says."
I really wanna respond thoughtfully.
I really wanna choose my words the right way.
I'm so excited.
I really am looking forward to her writing her book,
because I just think it is such a smart
and intelligent way to tell her story.
It'll get us all reading and off our screens,
so thank you Britney for that.
And she will control that narrative
and she will tell us in her own words.
And it's just a brilliant way
for us to be invited into her world.
And so in a response,
I just gotta choose my words carefully
'cause it is such a moment for me.
I have so many feelings towards her, so much profoundness.
So how do you encapsulate that in a post?
She managed to do it, now I gotta figure it out.
But really when you put your words out there,
Britney Spears, we're all listening.
So I'm really excited for your book.
Yeah, me too.
(audience clapping)
Me too, how cool.
I can't wait for her book
and I have to say, I've said it before, I'll say it again.
If she doesn't call her book stronger than yesterday,
girl, there's the title, am I right?
Can you tell her?
We have some unique journeys in common
and I don't posture to know her,
or understand her,
or say I'm like her or that our journeys align,
but there's just a tremendous amount
of understanding and empathy
that I have for her.
It's hard for me to put into words the way I feel about her,
but it is beautiful.
It is.
Yeah.
I would love to be a fly on a wall
for a conversation between the two of you.
That would be fascinating.
I would give anything
to be that fly too,
or the person, or any of it, any, oh my god!
(upbeat music)